hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transcendences.com so in this video guys
we're here to make a big update on
amcgme of course but as well triple q as
triple q there were some nice trades to
do this week i'm gonna go through that
and the major indicators that we keep an
eye on to know whenever this correction
is finally over and i can tell you that
today we have some good news and we have
some bad news so let's go through that
let's get into it all right guys amc
first
so here we go
uh as usual we're gonna go through the
indicators that i think are the basic
indicators that you need to use for your
technical analysis and then combine that
with you know a macroeconomic view and
build up a you know fundamental and
technical view
and use it for trading so here
uh
let's first
have a look at the volume so last friday
i told you guys that we have a nice
increase in volume i was trying to see
where it was coming from it was not that
clear
uh but as you can see the next day the
volume was still here and
this time we had a massive move up of 13
and we traded above the 13.5 level
so this was a very nice signal
um and then unfortunately didn't follow
up very nicely uh because there was
actually you know a
strong move down on the rest of the
market so amc resisted pretty well to me
uh we lost the momentum unfortunately
once again not because of amc guys you
know amc traders did what they had to
but
you can't fight when the whole market is
crashing and this is what happened here
uh we're gonna go through that so now
the volume has decreased
so we came back i would say slightly
bullish on the volume because we still
have uh this nice volume bars that
happened uh you know five days ago so
it's still bullish but
uh the volume has disappeared
so neutral but rsi still above 50 on the
daily so that's pretty good guys okay so
we're still bullish on the medium term
um
here
at i'm afraid we came back here to the
13
12.5 level i'm gonna discuss that with
you
uh why so just because you know we lost
the momentum and we still have some room
on diary size so maybe a pullback here
before a rebound could make sense i
would personally open a long position
here
on top of the position i already have
and i'm going to use a stop loss around
11.5 something like this i think this is
a nice trick to do this week
uh and here once again on the short term
i'm pretty neutral
all right it's that doesn't look so good
once again we lost the momentum
uh
i i don't know neutral on the short term
but i read the bullish on the medium
term
then what else do we have macd not
giving much information here
and we are above this trendline so once
again as long as we stay above you know
12 roughly
nice things can happen if we break out
below 12 we'll probably go to nine
alright so that's it for amc jimmy
uh this time gme is
uh has less bullish momentum than amc
you can see rsi at 47
on gme whereas it is at 53
on amc so it's you know
uh interesting to notice that because
usually it's the other way around jamie
was more bullish but
not this time uh all right so uh here
what can happen guys i don't know it
looks to me like maybe this was a one
three four five all right a first wave
and that's right now we are in a second
wave so second waves as you guys know
can be triangle a little yeah triangle
flat zigzag it's okay i still know it uh
and here it looks like a um flat to me a
b c so uh my take is that
uh
we might see once again if the rest of
the market is bullish we're going to
discuss that uh we might see a nice
bounce around 115 level okay
uh and then we are likely to go uh here
higher uh
and what we need to focus on is what's
going to happen around the 150 level as
you can see the 200-day moving average
is acting very well as resistance uh
here the past two three weeks so this is
a
a good indicator to follow if we're able
to go above that level with uh some
volume that would be a very good signal
and the major resistance to me is the
160 level so
uh two scenarios either 115 holes and
we're able to cross here and that could
give us guys this third wave that we are
waiting for for a very long time uh but
once again we need the rest of the
market to be bullish and on the other
way around if we break out below 115
it's not a strong support
but
i mean
it's the best we have
so i'm afraid that then we would
probably go to the hundred level and
from here go higher
or break out below here and this would
be really bad if this happens guys it's
really time to uh sell calls buy boots
you know keep your shares fine but take
protection all right
for now we're not there yet
so here we are in some kind of neutral
area same thing it's very hard to know
what's going to happen
no one is really in control but we are
potentially in a one-two so let's
monitor that now triple q that once
again is going to give us some
information about what the rest of the
market is doing what can you tell me
guys on triple q is it bullish or
bearish look at that
okay it's bearish right it's bearish we
have here a resistance that acted uh i
took this trade on s triple q you can do
the same kind of trend lines uh i
personally uh says triple q is the uh
three time short etf of triple q and you
can see here uh
we arrived on the resistance
in the same time s triple q was at
support at 50. i personally started to
buy at 53.5
uh so this is a winning trade i had a
stop loss here guys and
as i showed you in this code
this stop loss is uh bam bam bam so for
those who want to join this code link in
this description and for those who take
the platinum membership you have 60
discount on my course
uh and here on s triple q bam
yeah so you can see this i gave you this
trade
so here all right
okay so this was on monday we took this
trade by here stop loss here and then we
increase the stop loss okay
every day the stop loss is higher
following this trend line all right
so now the stop loss is here and i
personally gonna increase my position
if we are able to arrive if we retrace a
little bit more and i'm gonna keep to
move the stop loss with the whole
position all right because i think that
uh some bad things still might happen
all right so if we see something like
that i want to be very very short on
uh triple q so meaning we could have
here
uh come back here and then move lower so
this is one scenario we just come back
slightly to 280 to 90 and then we keep
dropping strongly with increasing volume
this would be really bad i would
probably go to you know really low
levels the alternative scenario which is
very possible and the reason why is look
at the u.s 10-year yield guys this is
the good news i wanted to show you
uh we are here coming back guys so the
u.s 10 year old is the measure of
inflation somehow
and just remember that the higher the
worse and the lower the better so here
you can see we came back after breakout
above this trend line that you can see a
30 years trend line guys
four years uh we broke out above that
level uh when things started to be
really bad uh we retested it we went
lower and now we are retesting it again
so this is quite good a us 10 yield
below 3 in these days is good news so i
like to see that and what i would like
to see even more is a breakout below
here the 20-week moving average that is
right now at 270 we broke out below the
50-day moving average as you can see
that acted very well as support
here uh two weeks ago when we had this
move down so here i remind you guys the
20 the u.s 10-year yield on uh
june may uh june 3rd
was here all right so may 27th june 30th
this area
sorry bam
it was uh when triple q was here all
right and then u.s 10 yield uh
rallied and triple two collapsed so is
the gonna is in this time
uh
this time we broke out below
the 50-day moving average so this is the
good news i wanted to show you and if
we're able to go even lower this would
be very good so maybe here we're gonna
have hero consideration and then the
breakout so we're going to monitor that
if this happens we have a very nice move
up to catch of around 15
on triple q so i'm going to stop of
course my position as triple two and i'm
going to open some positions on stocks
if i see some nice breakouts or on
triple q directly and i'm going to share
this in my discord
and here if this happens
we are here once again discussing when
the correction might be over and my uh
guess is first we need to have this this
would happen with the u.s 10 wheel that
will probably collapse if you see triple
q breaking out here above 290 but you
stand your yield going higher guys this
is a trap all right first thing to
remember
and then i remind you what we want to
see we want to see it uh triple two
coming back to 3 15. i'm afraid that we
go to 315 then drop brutally
so
whenever we are around 3 15 if we're
able to do to go here what are we gonna
look at to know if this is a trap or not
volume first thing do we have volume
here for now you can see
not really i mean the volume is not
giving indication if you have here some
strong moves up with some nice volume
just like we had here with the red bars
or just like we had here that was a nice
volume even if you know it got followed
by
just a consideration of two months three
months at least it was not something
bearish so here we need to see if the
volume is coming uh and especially we
need to see if the us 10 new yield is
around the 270 to 80 level and the vix
guys okay very important
look at the vix
uh bam bam bam you can see that right
now the
uh we have a nice resistance that is
here around the 35 level so of course if
you see the vix coin going above that it
means that we are dropping here we are
in in this area all right uh so first
thing to keep an eye on and
most importantly we wonder whenever the
correction is over and for the
correction to be over we need first to
go to 315
with some nice volume with a vix that is
here
coming back so you can see we have a
trendline that we can make on the vix
that is around
uh 26 right now so i think that the 26
level
is gonna go together here 25 26 this
blue trend line is going to go together
with a breakout above the 290 level okay
so first level to watch on vixx
here this breakout needs to go with this
breakout okay it could go together it
doesn't need but it's good if we see
those together and if we are close to
315 the vix will probably come back here
and if we're able to go below 20
with triple q being above 315 then guys
this is
the signal that the correction is
probably over and i'm very sure that the
us 10 yield will be around 270 to 60
and the xy as well that needs to go
lower
so that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i see you guys